a Las Vegas one step closer to pot
lounges yeah the city's Planning
Commission said to green line two
proposed venues at tomorrow night's
meeting Lauren granny joining us live
downtown in the arts district where one
of those lounges would go this is such a
popular spot Lauren the arts district
for locals and for tourists
definitely that's one of the reasons why
the owners of the building State could
be a real economic boost for that reason
alone it's actually right here behind me
of my shoulder here at 4 000 square foot
hot Lounge that could be opening up down
here over there between creamy and the
beauty shop now that company again the
owners there the corner building LLC
bought the whole building pretty
recently they'll have to follow some of
those rules that were set back in March
there like no alcohol served inside and
no smoking outside now the owners say
the business will be again an economic
boost to the area and there still must
be a 1 000 feet between each lounge and
between lounges and schools there the
other site is over near isn't going to
be an 8 000 square foot site near Desert
Inn Road and Rancho now as far as this
you know again this is just another step
here in this ongoing process something
we've been talking about for a long time
it seems and time will tell what the Las
Vegas city councilors vote when their
time comes for now live near Main Street
and California Avenue Laura Negrete
eight news now